[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera
Allora vorrei che immaginaste un mare
tumultuoso con onde alte e potenti che
si infrangono con forza e creano uno
scoglio imponente ogni onda presa
individualmente può sembrare
insistificante incapace di causare un
vero e proprio cambiamento Ma quando
molte onde si uniscono formano la marea
che non può essere ignorata le onde
rappresentano le voci di coloro che si
battono per la giustizia sociale per il
cambiamento su una forza incisiva e
trasformativa in grado di erodere le
strutture consolidate della nostra
società insieme queste onde queste voci
crescono con forza e potenza proprio
come le onde del mare che si uniscono
non è un caso infatti che il motto di
diverse manifestazioni sia proprio siamo
Marea
in questa marea possiamo essere una
forza indomabile che crea un nuovo
Orizzonte di uguaglianza amore
comprensione cura come avete potuto
immaginare questa metafora ci ricorda
che anche una singola voce può fare la
differenza fare rumore il rumore nella
sua definizione comune è spesso
associato al fastidio all'inconveniente
ma nell'ambito dell'attivismo e della
divulgazione il rumore assume un
significato profondo rappresenta La
scomodità necessaria per portare avanti
la lotta per la giustizia
se non sei scomodo non lo stai facendo
nel modo giusto è il motto delle stanze
del femminismo e sottolinea l'importanza
di uscire dalla propria zona di comfort
e mettersi in discussione e provocare il
cambiamento ponendosi in modo critico
davanti a quella che ci viene raccontata
come la normalità il rumore in questi
termini si riferisce la creazione di una
consapevolezza collettiva sulle
questioni sociali attraverso proteste
manifestazioni campagne mediatiche e
altro ancora è una forma di espressione
potente che consente a chiunque di far
sentire la propria voce Con l'avvento
dei social media e della comunicazione
globale la voce di un solo individuo può
raggiungere una vasta platea come nel
mio caso nel lontano 2020 decide di
utilizzare la mia pagina personale la
mia voce per denunciare una serie di
episodi razzisti così la pagina che
avevo creato per parlare di studio e
delle mie riflessioni si è trasformata
nel mio spazio personale in cui racconto
la mia esperienza da donna nera neuro
divergente in Italia Ho unito piano
piano le mie conoscenze di
giurisprudenza con i saggi femministi
antirazzisti e per questo nonostante che
mi considero una persona logorroica
riesco a riassumere concetti brevemente
in modo comprensibile inizialmente Lo
facevo per me stessa e per le persone
che erano nella mia vita affinché io
potessi trovare un modo di spiegare le
discriminazioni che subivo poi ho
iniziato per farlo per riappropriarmi di
tutte le mie caratteristiche identitarie
e anche detto terra terra per rispondere
alle persone che mi rompevano le scatole
per non usare un francesismo con il
tempo il mio profilo è cresciuto sempre
di più ma io non trovo un modo per
definirlo per definire quello che facevo
inizialmente lasciavo che le persone mi
chiamassero attivista ma poi ho
cominciato a sentire questo termine
inappropriatico inappropriato l'unico
termine che sentivo rappresentarmi era
divulgazione e ho iniziato a specificare
a tutti e tutte di chiamarmi
divulgatrice perché il mio non era
attivi vedremo come lo penso io perché
quando penso all'attivismo mi vengono in
mente Angela Davis belux Rosa Parks
Malcom X mentre io sono una semplice
ragazza di Trezzano sul Naviglio che ha
deciso di utilizzare la sua voce e la
sua penna per fare un minimo di
differenza nella sua vita e nella vita
delle altre persone nel mio percorso Ho
fatto tanti errori continua a farli e
probabilmente ne farò ancora ma non mi
sono mai messa sul piedistallo
appropiandomi di ruolo di ruoli o
distanze ho utilizzato il mio spazio
personale per essere me stessa e
soprattutto per difendere me stessa e
portare avanti i mediali Ribadisco non
mi definisco attivista perché come dico
io La mia è una esistenza Resistenza
quotidiana che mi permette di non stare
più in silenzio allo stesso tempo però
non voglio che la parola attivismo vi
spaventi perché nel termine attivismo
c'è la parola attivi possiamo essere
attivi in diversi modi l'attivismo in
realtà può diventare uno stile di vita
quotidiano che si manifesta ovunque che
sia a cena con gli amici
nostra famiglia al lavoro ogni
conversazione ogni azione ogni scelta
può contribuire a diffondere
consapevolezza promuovendo l'uguaglianza
e sfidando le ingiustizie Per non
rimanere spettatori passivi di un
sistema che discrimina le persone in
base al sesso all'etnia all'orientamento
sessuale alla disabilità o la
conformazione del proprio corpo e possa
andare avanti io sono stata in qualche
modo obbligata a prendere questa strada
perché ho deciso di vivere e smettere di
sopravvivere Ma secondo voi perché
alcune persone non sentono queste
esigenze perché alcuni quando si parla
di determinati stanze si tratta di una
esagerazione ormai non è più così
Ora vorrei chiedervi per alzata di mano
Chi conosce il concetto di privilegio
Ok cercherò di riassumerlo brevemente i
privilegi nel contesto degli studi
dell'attivismo Sono spessi definiti sono
spesso definiti come vantaggi e benefici
sociali politici economici di cui godono
alcuni persone o gruppi di persone per
la loro appartenenza determinate
categorie sociali come genere etnia
classe sociale orientamento eccetera
eccetera L'analisi dei privilegi avviene
come parte di una critica sociale
cercando di evidenziare le
disuguaglianze sistemiche e le disparità
di potere che possono derivare dai
privilegi queste ricerche spesso
includono l'idea che il privilegio non
sia semplicemente un vantaggio ma un
sistema di vantaggi che influenzano le
opportunità gli accessi e trattamenti
differenziali tra diverse persone o
gruppi nella società per rafforzare il
concetto voglio portarvi alcuni esempi
trattamento preferenziale da parte delle
autorità Cosa significa le persone
bianche spesso ricevono un trattamento
più favorevole da parte delle forze
dell'ordine e del sistema giudiziario
questo può manifestarsi nell'essere
trattati con maggiori rispetto nel
ricevere piene più lievi o nell'essere
meno soggetti ai controlli delle forze
dell'ordine
un altro esempio è l'accesso
privilegiato all'occupazione e
all'istruzione le persone bianche
possono avere maggiori opportunità di
lavoro e di istruzione possono avere un
accesso agevolato a posizioni di potere
salari più alti maggiori opportunità di
carriera rispetto alle persone con un
background migratorio con le stesse
qualifiche andando avanti l'assenza di
stereotipi negativi le persone bianche
non devono confrontarsi con stereotipi
negativi pregiudizi diffusi che possono
influenzare la loro reputazione le loro
interazioni sociali e le loro
opportunità di vita questo può garantire
loro una maggiore libertà di espressione
e soprattutto di autodeterminazione un
altro esempio è la rappresentazione
mediatica positiva in media spesso
rappresentano la bellezza l'intelligenza
il successo attraverso una prospettiva
Bianca ciò può influenzare l'autostima e
le aspettative delle persone favorendo
l'identificazione e la valorizzazione
dei tratti e dei modelli di vita
biancocentrici
l'assenza di denterogatori sulla propria
identità Ma da dove viene No intendo Da
dove vieni Veramente Ma parli benissimo
italiano Eh beh sono nata qua le persone
bianche possono dare per scontato il
loro background non devono affrontare
interrogatori o discussioni sulle
proprie origini O sulla propria etnia
ciò deriva dal fatto che il bianco è
considerato lo standard e non richiede
spiegazioni O giustificazioni questi
sono solo alcuni esempi potrei andare
avanti e fare tre tettonica di quello
che viene definito come White Privilege
il White Privilege può influenzare la
vita delle persone bianche in modo
positivo creando disparità e
disuguaglianze all'interno della società
ma adesso una volta capito di possedere
un privilegio cosa posso fare
Allora avere un privilegio non è
assolutamente una colpa ma lo diventa
quando non lo si usa per fare la
differenza e attenzione Non parlo
dell'indignazione temporanea per il caso
razzista che diventa mediatico ma parlo
di una pratica continua ad esempio se un
vostro conoscente utilizza un termine
offensivo o fa una battuta
discriminatoria stare in silenzio vi
rende complici di quella battuta e del
mantenimento dello status quo perché
erroneamente da quello che si pensa in
Italia di razzismo si muore la lista
delle vittime è lunga è solo che viene
sempre tenuta nascosta a volte in un
silenzio che fa rumore
nonostante la marea di cui abbiamo
parlato prima sia un concetto potente
non è immune da critiche da contrasti
interni le persone Hanno diverse
caratteristiche identitarie e di
conseguenza subiscono diversi
discriminazioni e godono di diversi
privilegi le donne nere nella storia del
femminismo hanno lottato affinché
venisse riconosciuta l'intersezione tra
genere etnia e classi sociali e su come
le discriminazioni si manifestano in
modo differente a seconda delle proprie
caratteristiche identitarie per questo è
importante non lasciare nessuna persona
indietro
l'intersezionalità nel femminismo è come
una mappa che mostra delle strade che si
intersecano per riconoscere le
molteplici identità e le esperienze che
le persone vivono il privilegio del
femminismo può essere descritto invece
come una scala mobile che dà da alcune
persone un vantaggio in partenza come il
fatto di avere la pelle bianca rendendo
più facile il loro cammino nella lotta
per i diritti civili Mentre mentre altre
persone devono affrontare ostacoli
maggiori a causa delle loro identità
marginalizzate così nasce il concetto di
sorellanza di cura per le proprie
sorelle e anche quello di alleanza nelle
battaglie che non ci toccano
personalmente
Ma come si fa a parlare di sorellanza di
solidarietà in una società che promuove
l'individualismo l'idea del successo
dell'essere sempre al centro come dice
Deluxe la sorellanza non poteva essere
potente Finché le donne erano in
competizione e in guerra tra loro
sapevamo che non poteva esserci una vera
sorella una vera sorellanza tra donne
bianche e donne nere se le prime non
riuscivano a liberarsi dalla supremazia
Bianca se il MoVimento femminista non
era sostanzialmente anti razzista è
necessario ritornare alle origini
ricordando che l'essere umano è un
animale sociale e che da soli non
andiamo da nessuna parte e che i veri
cambiamenti le rivoluzioni sono partiti
dal popolo dal basso Ricordatevi ogni
giorno che non esistono lotte singole la
mia lotta è la vostra lotta e di tutte e
di tutti dobbiamo impegnarci a
combattere ogni forma di discriminazione
dalla più piccola alla più manifesta
metterci in discussione
sue opere Il silenzio dobbiamo
decostruire tutti quei baias e quelli
stereotipi che abbiamo interiorizzato
dalla società questo percorso non è
facile incontrerete delle difficoltà
alcuni rapporti termineranno una sorta
di pulizia contatti come mi piace dire
anche se il peso della anche se il peso
della consapevolezza a volte picchiaduro
ogni tanto non vi nascondo che vorrei
sbattere la testa e come dico io tornare
in scena ma poi mi ricordo che non era
una vita vera normalizzavo trattamenti
discriminatori degradanti per
conformarmi a una realtà per non dare
fastidio per non fare rumore
minimizzavo tutto mandavo giù diversi
rospi fino a che ho detto basta perché
come dice taran abork in silenzio Non
protegge i nostri diritti il silenzio
alimenta il complice e per concludere
come dice la mia più grande fonte di
ispirazione Può darsi che non siate
responsabili per la situazione in cui
per la situazione in cui vi trovate Ma
lo Diventerete se non farete nulla per
cambiarla
Grazie
[Applauso]